hey guys so it's been a while since I've
done a cooking video and I have a very
special one today because I have two
very special things a special guest it's
Jenna yeah just me the other special
thing let's go show them so today we're
going to be making a cake it's gonna be
a sasquatch cake I don't even know what
to tell you is gonna happen because I
have no idea this is my new child don't
worry I will still definitely be using a
blender in my life for this video we're
gonna test it out
the woman said that we use this one for
cakes and stuff the black one they
should go out a flag oh don't do that
look it even came with all these things
what to do what she called that one it
was like a wide whisk heat oven to 350
for shiny metal or glass pan 325 is that
shiny metal first off gets look at the
pan pan size is that yeah I guess mine
is it is just put it in the oven will do
350 I'll figure this out here no but you
need to know how long the hell pizza pan
is for help it's 350 yeah I know it's
350 but you have to know how long the
coldest any other hand side
Russia's absolutely I have no idea
I've never made anything before in my
life those pretty solid Justin yes sorry
you won't want a donor get ya doin uh
what what's up in you know look at why
oh yeah cake mix water oil a large bowl
most be I'm just gonna just put this in
there okay we're told done a lot of
hands-on don't actually these for
cooking way is that two or one I mean
for you we can always replay the footage
hello
yes three cool all right half a cup of
vegetable oil this is one cup so we'll
just do half fish fish three-point bunch
of bullies eggs
I mean okay now what do I do
I can't stop cuz they're gonna hit each
other cut everyone down the bowl no no
no I cannot wait to use this mixer it
was for breast cancer
there's nothing pink in there I think it
might be blood from the hey chicken
period it doesn't matter okay snot oh
it's not plugged in oh great first time
is a charm
a mixer oh you know what else these are
done is that was our hands know hey Mel
good mixer do this occasionally up when
he gets the honey
Oh what against the high speeds yeah but
I can even do that with a stop it I'm
not sure I've never made a cake before
shut up love you
yeah anyway I've watched our mom make a
cake we made a cake by myself
my guess nobody wants to do for two
minutes how long do we cook the cake for
that's what I was trying to ask you
about the pan sizing you heard because I
matter just put it something like
something like 20 28 to 30 hell do I
have to grease a pan Syria do I have to
grease a baking pan what I'm making a
cake here okay just yep what do you what
what what is the problem I think that's
good yeah 28 to 33 minutes okay could
you open the oven please
while our cake bakes and cools we're
gonna go to dinner and we come back it's
party time
well we're not gonna leave wild oven is
on that's true make sure you two tips
we're gonna let the cake cool and when I
come back
prepare for decorating masterpieces or a
mess not really sure all right welcome
back we're going to decorate the cake
and yes we are in fact on the floor but
it is a freshly cleaned floor and don't
do anything I do ever Oh anymore this is
actually edible - oh boy I'm really
excited to eat it
well you know I'm not left-handed oh I
can be not left-handed I got some cake
in it oh no
here you do it just put the cake back oh
no it's really good that's a really nice
line keep it going
reference material focus on like squash
okay you get the point
they try your belt medal at my arms I'm
trying actually really hard
you need to Edward
all right Squatch cake is complete what
do you guys say it's focused on you
focus on Squatch really go
mmm that's a really dry moist cake it's
not moist at all thank you guys for
watching make sure you subscribe if you
like this video please click like make
sure you check out Jenna's channel and
leave me some comments what you think I
should attempt to cook next I didn't
film too bad this time no it's not bad
it's not good though it's just dry for a
moist cake it's dry do it later